[Música]
fala pessoal meu nome é Lucas de graça
eu queria agradecer muito esse convite
da Tex do início para falar um pouquinho
do futuro do Brasil em relação à
sustentabilidade e desenvolvimento
econômico tão título desse Sedex toque é
o Brasil carbono zero então eu vou
começar um pouco contando a minha
história como eu cheguei até aqui porque
eu tô falando sobre sustentabilidade
desenvolvimento econômico quem soro
eu na verdade
comecei eu nasci em São Paulo Cristina
em São Paulo e não era nada mais do que
o menino com sonho de ser piloto de
carro de corrida o meu ídolo Everton
Sena como eram de muitos brasileiros e
Eu segui esse sonho desde pequenininho é
apoiado pela minha família e sempre
seguir tentando realizar esse sonho para
pedir comecei no kart depois fui para a
fórmula foi campeão mundial de Fórmula 3
vezes campeão mundial de Fórmula 2 fui
para Fórmula 1 x 1 Temporada de Fórmula
1 depois ficou ruim híbridos e em 2012
surgiu a oportunidade na minha vida que
foi a criação de uma categoria
100% elétrico 2012 Eu fui o segundo
empregado da forma e para quem não sabe
a forma é um campeonato mundial de
Fórmula 1 = Fórmula 1 mas com bateria e
motor elétrico e o automobilismo sempre
serviu a dois propósitos muito
importantes
distintos um do outro o primeiro é o
entretenimento nas corridas servem como
inspiração como fonte de entretenimento
como todos os outros esportes mas a
corrida também serve como
desenvolvimento tecnológico e a gente na
forma e já viu isso em 2012 que
realmente não é o futuro do automóvel da
mobilidade urbana principalmente seria
elétrico então gente eu resolvi apostar
minhas fichas e nos últimos sete anos a
forma existe há 7 anos eu tive
excelentes memórias sempre tentando
levantar a bandeira do Brasil no lugar
mais alto do Podium
Então é isso que a gente construiu e o
que foi feito até agora e por isso que a
fórmula e me deu uma série de
possibilidades de se juntar a ONU como
Embaixador Mundial para a qualidade do
ar para o ar puro né E que é um dos
fatores mais importantes que a gente vai
falar depois porque os veículos
elétricos veículos de emissão Zero eles
são tão importantes no centro da cidade
estava as mais importantes do que a
parte do aquecimento global e carbono
zero é realmente as emissões que a gente
respira morando em cidades grandes como
São Paulo São Paulo e fui na Copa esse
ano cop26 falar sobre isso
fui visitar
a maior usina
normal Usina solar fotovoltaica é
térmica do mundo em Marrakech foi no
reator de fusão nuclear do Inter na
França falei no WhatsApp me enfim
usei a forma aí e essa proposta e
valores da forma e desenvolver
tecnologias sustentáveis sempre tentando
colocar essa mensagem para frente que a
gente consegue ter como a mobilidade
elétrica
em um mundo que vai ter mobilidade
melhor vai melhorar qualidade das
pessoas é o mesmo tempo né transformar a
mobilidade em algo mais democrático para
tirar o custo da mobilidade se ela for
100% elétrico eu vou explicar mas para a
gente ter mobilidade Elétrica A gente
precisa ter o quê produção de energia
renovável não adianta a gente produzir
energia
com carvão e querer depois usar
mobilidade elétrica não é compatível e o
Brasil está na posição essencial para a
gente conseguir fazer isso mas primeiro
eu queria só deixar claro que
sustentabilidade na minha opinião não é
o conceito de parar de usar eletricidade
para usar menos algo a gente precisa
usar mais eletricidade aumentar Nossa
qualidade de vida principalmente nos
países em desenvolvimento tá você pode
ver no caso da América do Sul Índia e
África a gente precisa usar mais energia
para produzir mais energia que o Brasil
é um caso único no mundo que a gente vai
conseguir produzir energia mais barata
mais energia e ao mesmo tempo energia de
fontes renováveis a gente tem uma
combinação única
a matriz energética do Brasil já é
praticamente
renovável né a gente tem as 70% da
energia produzida por hidrelétricas como
essa foto mostra Itaipu é uma gigante a
segunda maior do mundo só pode promover
na hidrelétrica da China mas produz
eletricidade com carbono zero na água
serve como um
[Música]
potencial gravitacional da água turbina
ela gera
energia elétrica gera eletricidade e o
Brasil tem mais uma coisa muito
importante que depois a gente vai
combinar com a produção hidrelétrica o
Brasil eu tenho uma capacidade
fotovoltaica uma incidência solar muito
alto eles podem ver nesse mapa aqui no
ponto botei Power potente do Brasil é um
dos maiores do mundo e isso não dá para
você conseguir ser geograficamente
uma do Brasil tem a gente tá perto do
Equador e perto do Equador significa que
a gente tem muito sol e a gente tem
muito sol e muita área então os nossos
painéis Solares no Brasil que são muito
eficientes o custo de no vácuo hora né
da energia produzida pelos nossos
painéis Solares Eles são de duas a três
vezes mais eficiente que os mesmos
painéis Solares na Europa ou no norte
dos Estados Unidos porque sistema
incidência solar muito alta então vocês
podem ver aqui ó nesse quadradinho
daquele para vocês verem nesse
quadradinho de 40 por 40 Km é o que a
gente precisa para produzir
para produzir esse
183 Mega
dele tá que a gente já produzem Então se
a gente fizer um quadradinho desse
tamanho do tamanho desse Amarelinho aqui
exatamente por 40 por 40 km de painéis
fotovoltaicos a gente produz
100% a mais só de energia fotovoltaica
mas daí vai falar mais
voltar então
não tem a noite como é que a gente faz a
onde armazenar energia fotovoltaica e a
gente tem a gente volta a falar das
hidrelétricas que a gente tem
dois pontos aqui muito importante a
gente tem aqui nessa nessa foto que mexe
nesse gráfico de cima da esquerda a
gente tem que chama que a gente
então durante o dia se é o painel solar
tá produzindo muita energia
usina hidrelétrica serve como uma
bateria ela bombeia água para cima com
excesso de eletricidade e à noite quando
não bate o sol ouvir a mente a água
desce e Jerry cidade então essa
combinação de placa solar e hidrelétrica
é fundamental Não dá para você ter só
placa solar Porque a noite você tá
demais energia ou precisa tomar outro
sinal funcionando no Brasil a gente ter
os dois Além disso aqui como vocês podem
ver a gente pode usar já os lagos Davi
hidrelétricas para adicionar placa solar
em nossas placas flutuantes são muito
eficientes né porque uma das fatores que
muda a eficiência totalmente eficiente
da placa solar é uma fatura do cooler E
quanto a gente consegue resfriar as
placas a gente tem área suficiente na
verdade em Belo Monte a área que foi
inundada para fazer Belo Monte produzirá
produziria Mais eletricidade das se você
descobrisse aquele lá com placa solar do
que a própria usina de Belo Monte
Candinho já tenho cliente já tenho todo
o potencial é só instalar as placas
solares
que placa fotovoltaica pode ser usada de
forma segregada de forma espalhada
nenhum só como a gente ficou ali em cima
naquele quadradinho aqui isso é só para
demonstrar a área que o Brasil precisa
de fotos voltar para produzir sempre
neném atualmente a gente pode usar o
totalmente a placa solar segregado então
todas as residências no Brasil que tem
uma área em insolação
suficiente poderia ter placa solar e
essa produção de placa solar é de fontes
renováveis dá-lhe acesso a gente fazer a
introdução da nova mobilidade elétrica
Veículos Elétricos 2.0 veículos modernos
onde é mais eficiente a gente usar
veículo elétrico onde os veículos são
usados de formas mais constantes então
por exemplo se acabam
carro individual não a gente tem que
fazer primeiro essa transição para
mobilidade elétrica em veículos que usam
são usados durante muitas horas do dia
então pode ser Vans de entrega de
logística principalmente nas áreas
urbanas e ônibus e caminhões
Eu também dentro de complexos urbanos e
que rodam durante muitas horas por dia
então o principal a principal
eletrificação da fralda tem que começar
com veículos comerciais e públicos e daí
sim e para veículos individuais a
quantidade de genes estão direitos
individuais é muito pequena perto dos
outros veículos de Frota comercial e
publica
isso é exatamente o tava falando é a
parte da poluição nessa foto de 23 e 30
de maio foi quando teve a greve dos
caminhoneiros em São Paulo e a gente
pode ver claramente e domingo greve
caminhoneiros novamente causou uma série
de problemas mas põe um estudo né Foi um
caso que deu para estudar o quanto a
poluição do ar é melhorou na cidade de
São Paulo eu tava lá eu lembro mudou a
qualidade das pessoas Então se a gente
conseguir Electro Brota a gente vai ter
uma qualidade de vida muito melhor mas
aí a pergunta vai ficar mais barato ou
mais caro mas se a gente eletrificar
Frota agora eu fiz um estudo rápido para
a gente entender se fazia sentido nenhum
veículo
elétrico agora ou não estou aqui vocês
podem ver nesse gráfico que eu fiz
Veículos Elétricos versus híbridos
versus álcool e versos de gasolina então
eu coloquei eu coloquei aqui um preço
vocês podem ver no ano 1
preços reais então aqui nesse caso
Renault Zoe custa r$
152000 e um equivalente que é um
Chevrolet Spin
na faixa de r$ 90000 então custo de
aquisição do veículo de gasolina e
elétrico tem uma diferença grande uma
diferença aí de r$ 60000 para veículo
que vale 90 mas
100 Km por dia e considerando gasolina
r$ 6 e a eletricidade 50 centavos o
quilowatt-hora
a gente consegue você consegue ver aqui
acompanha o gráfico você vai consumir
muito mais
gasolina do que eletricidade e no mais
ou menos no ano 4 depois que você
comprou o veículo você gastou a mesma
coisa né uns veículos é a curva se
conversa então se você ficar 4 anos o
veículo significa tem um custo extra que
você teve que pagar na Elektro você
depois
recuperou não tendo que encher o tanque
e Tainá considerando a gasolina que tá
barato né já tá subindo muito mais
rápido e se a gente tiver energia
sobressalente os veículos elétricos
podem ser carregados a qualquer ponto do
dia então você pode usar já esta curso
daí já vai cair se tiver né mais energia
produzida do que utilizada Então esse
curso energia tende a cair e se você
usar a própria energia placa solar na
sua própria casa você consegue ter preço
da ainda menores que ele e usar o seu
veículo como bateria da sua casa então
por exemplo você não tá tendo gerador E
se tiver alguma falta de que é muito
cara por exemplo você pode usar o carro
como fonte de energia para sua casa
então o carro o carro elétrico soma dos
carros elétricos vão servir para
estabilizar o vidro elétrico no longo
prazo Então esse você precisa diminuir
também investimento em infraestrutura
linha de transmissão não tá aqui é só
queria deixar terminando aqui o top
sobre o como a gente pode acelerar a
transição para a produção de energia
fotovoltaica no Brasil faz todo sentido
custo faz sentido o curso porque não
acho já é mais barato do que as
hidrelétricas novas ou qualquer outra
forma de eletricidade mesmo de
combustíveis fósseis isso não é não é o
caso em países europeus por causa da
nossa incidência solar que a gente tem
um potencial muito alto e com energia
barata os veículos elétricos da vez
melhores principalmente a gente colocar
em conta a quantidade
de problemas que a gente tem por causa
da qualidade do ar são mais de no mundo
inteiro mais de 7 milhões de mortos por
ano nosso prematuros por causa da má
qualidade do ar e um grande responsável
é o veículo de combustão interna como a
gente tem que começar pela Frota
comercial e assim que o custo que tiver
mais produção de vidro elétrico atende
seu preço tá aí ainda mais bateu ficarem
mais baratas com energia renovável o
Brasil pode dar esse passo para
mobilidade de uma forma muito rápida que
faça sentido econômico para todo mundo
gerando empregos gerando valor na cadeia
e melhorando a qualidade de vida de
todos os brasileiros Espero que você
tenha gostado te vejo uma próxima vez
[Música]